is here the blue Air checking out the
box score do you really care about the
boxer you don't need all of a said this
Champion that's the only thing you need
to see is it says champion on there you
won the thing right the box score
doesn't matter at this point no matter
at all when you came back from the
injury and you came back to camp and you
saw the additions Bruce Brown contavious
Caldwell a couple guys brought in to
address deficiencies on this team when
did you think that this night was
possible honestly you know the first
time we went to the playoffs we played
um San Antonio and then we played
Portland and I I just felt this
just a tattoo young for for you know I'm
saying like we were really good yeah we
just we ain't been there before and um I
knew from that moment a couple of games
couple more experiences we're gonna be
right where we want to be um and just to
see like I say you know see it full
circle have us ever ever have everybody
healthy
um it's just really real special
um proud of my guys everybody on this
team is so unselfish and I think that's
why we're the best team in the league
speaking of unselfish I look at your
game and how unselfish that you've been
as far as your play making and
developing we've always known you could
score since Kentucky but I've seen you
grow so much in the pick and roll
especially in key moments talk about
that and how you see the game
differently than when you first came in
this league in those playoff games that
you were talking about uh I think just
slowing the game down
um
and not not forcing it you know I know I
can I know I can go one-on-one on a lot
of guys
um but if Joker's the better match that
throw to right and if I'm gonna double
the pickle you know throw this open man
um just being aggressive even in my
drives you know what I'm saying like I
don't have to score I can just put
pressure on the defense and everything's
been opened up so I think just finding
different ways to impact the game when
my shot's not dropping and um playing
defense just I know I'm not gonna be
perfect but if I bring that same energy
every night it's gonna be tough to stop
us so it's your mind gonna actually
nothing about the game oh all right I'm
just gonna ask you how you feel
[Laughter]
no I did so you you touched on something
about you know just being the best you
know you're the best team in the world
right now you can arguably say hey and
legitimately say I'm the best at my
position joke is the best at his
position now somebody May dispute that
you know a week from now or a year from
now but in this moment right now there's
no disputing who's the best and that is
you how do you feel and and tell me
about that joyous feeling that you're
feeling right now knowing that my team's
the best team in the world that's
playing yeah um I'm gonna touch on a few
things I think you know this for me
personally you know off ACL yeah
I didn't have a summer to really work on
what I wanted to work on you know what
I'm saying like it was just rehab yeah
and just getting my strength up to where
I needed to be and just like I know
there's another level for me and I
definitely know there's another yolk
Mike AG we're such an unselfish team
um we all give the spacing we need for
each other to work and if something's
open we pass it if it's not we go
somewhere else
um you know for myself
my bad nah hold on go ahead go ahead
collect yourself
you know because you got got a lot of
people watching and this is a moment
where where you are inspiring a lot of
people because there are a lot of people
who are down and looking at you right
now for some inspiration right this is
the moment that you can Inspire those
young kids who are out there who having
that difficult time that you went
through knee surgeries and everything
else people down them pops mom hard on
them give them some inspiration right
now uh for me you know just coming up
this is where this is where I dreamed of
being you know hitting a big shot in on
the biggest stage
um I I really live for those moments
like you know that's really fun for me
like that's why I play
um and everybody in the locker room
knows that I think everybody in the
league knows I want to be honest
um
and I just remember like I said
commentating
a whole playoff series like I would
write down one through eight for both
sides right and be on one team and and
commentate like Marvel Jordan for three
got it you know what I'm saying like
right right so like it's really been in
my mind dreaming about it reminiscing
um uh visualizing you know I'm saying so
just to see it come through and to enjoy
and just have fun with the moment it
just it hits home and I have my family
here I got my little bro who's who's on
the come up and he's looking at me you
know uh in the stands like it's just
it's just surreal and I just want to be
the best example for him and all the
people that coming off injuries at a
young age yes like you like talk to him
talk to him God give us the the
strongest or the toughest battles to the
strongest soldiers like you can do it
and you put your mind to it you can
really do it
um and I'm just another example and you
know Zach Levine helped me out a lot
just with my confidence all the depot
hurt back and forth again just he has
such a positive mindset talking to me it
was it was crazy clay like he wasn't he
was brutally
honestly honest with me how it's going
to be and I I talk about that
Brotherhood oh man I can see I could see
the hurt in his eyes when he talked to
me and that's how I it wasn't even it
was less about the words that he was
saying yeah I was looking at him
visually and I was looking he wasn't
even making eye contact he was just like
this is how it's going to be and now
when I talk to people that's the same
thing I'm like yeah this is how it's
going to be you know I'm saying so just
to see it full circle put your mind to
some Blood Sweat and Tears uh they're
real uh it's surreal to see this moment
well Jamal we we well documented how you
work when you're a youngster well
documented how you work through this
rehab but for me I was telling the guys
to me you was conditioned mentally you
never was fatigued at the down at the
end of the games and I wasn't talking
about your shot it seemed like you were
mentally strong to go through this what
prepared for you for mentally to go
through this because physically you were
there I'd say for me uh my dad helped me
out a lot with that you know what I'm
saying like you could have a bad
shooting night but you could have a good
game I think a lot of people don't
understand that like you can shoot
terrible and be one of the most
important people on the court yeah
um and I just try to bring the energy if
I miss a shot okay get a stop
communicate on defense get a rebound
give an extra rotation make a nice pass
and get back on defense like there's so
many other things you can do other than
putting the ball in the hoop here
congrats congrats man way to bring it
home way to bring it home let's go
celebrate tomorrow let me let me give
you a full circle moment
Toronto
Brenda Malone first coach of the Toronto
Raptors
Mike Malone his son
sees you y'all share this moment
together that's your full circle moment
yeah um you know coming in this league
like me and yo came off the bench
um
and we wait a minute wait a minute y'all
came off the bench yeah that's correct
that's crazy yeah that's crazy
um we came up the bench and um
we just grew chemistry like that's where
it started we just whatever the game
gives you you play with and we're both
good enough to make the reads off that
so when we call the play like
it's hard to explain there's so many
audibles to it depending on what they're
doing and you know they're blitzing me
they're doubling him and we still figure
it out and and Everybody Eats you know
Mike I knew Mike was gonna have a good
game he was due for it
um you know Jeff huge huge three huge
defensive stopping last game like it
it's not two guys you got to go to
everybody everybody Bruce if they're
gonna not take a body off me and then
Bruce go to work willingly go ahead like
this is a team effort I can't it's I
mean yolks MVP deservedly so
so just to see about how he's grown his
aggression has grown
um and I think he's got another level to
take it um
the rest of the league better be on
notice the level he's at right now is
pretty good the folks behind you are
saying stop stop talking let him go let
him go celebrate
NBA
[Music]